hello steve kaufman here the linguist on
language where i
like to talk about uh language learning
and things
vaguely related to language learning and
my own views of language learning
language learning is largely a matter of
attitude i've said this many many times
attitude not aptitude
it's how you feel about yourself how you
feel about the language
the interest the confidence
the willingness to put in the time these
are all the things that will determine
whether you're going to be successful or
not
um
the other day i was reading the
newspaper here in in canada and there
was a report published
that
discovered the fact that uh they that
what they did was they they
sent out uh
answers to job postings on these big job
sites like monster.com and so forth
and what they did was they had
four more or less similar uh
applications
one one of which where the applicant had
an english-sounding lane like mary smith
or john williams
and the other three had either
obviously pakistani or
muslim names
indian names
and chinese names
but totally chinese not james wong but
wong jiang or something
and what they discovered was that um
the
applications that were
from people with obviously english names
got a 16 callback
whereas applications with these other
names foreign sounding names got 11
callback
and this was presented as a major
discovery and so forth
i don't see what's surprising about that
that to me is perfectly normal they
found that where the applicant with the
foreign sounding name
had worked in canada for a year that
increased the number of callbacks
if a person instead of putting their
name as lei lee
wrote their name as mary lee they were
also much more likely to get a call back
and this was presented as an example of
racism
or possibly racism and so forth
um
you know as someone who has been
i have hired
many immigrants in fact at any given
time 30 40 percent of my workforce is
immigrant
i have hired
three people from the people's republic
of china
uh with people from japan people from
taiwan worked with me for a long time
romania russia
i can't think of them all
um
the ability to communicate is absolutely
crucial
and i'm not talking about accents i'm
talking about the ability to communicate
comfortably
our employee from
taiwan
had very noticeable accent but had no
trouble communicating
we have an employee from japan who i
wouldn't say is a tremendous
communicator but she makes up
for it in other ways
we had an employee from romania who is a
programmer
very difficult
just difficult and it is a delight and
we have had two employees from russia
we had one from china who was impossible
and which is and he was behind me
starting up
uh what subsequently became link because
i realized that there are so many people
like him
and and so what we have in canada over
the last six ten years our labor market
has been flooded
with immigrants who are looking for work
which is normal because we have a lot of
immigrants
who are in the sort of skilled worker
category and whose english is not very
good
and
so that anybody i mean five six years
ago i was much more positive towards
hiring people from china let's say than
i am today because i have come to
realize that many of them have serious
communication problems
and anyone that's in the business of
hiring people has been
you know
had many many such experiences
uh
we once applied
for a customer service person
for link
and we wanted someone who was bilingual
in english and chinese because at that
time we were working very
hard to try to develop the chinese
market i had over 40 i think 44
applications came in
uh essentially from people who were
originally immigrants and who had gone
to university in canada and out of the
44
four
were in correct english all the others
had some kind of mistake on them
i mentioned this to a lady whom i know
who's originally from
china and who is a professor at a local
community college and i told her how
surprised i was and she said she wasn't
surprised at all
uh we have i have had uh people who are
studying at university here
uh
say to me that it's unfair
that the professor uh gives them lower
marks because of their poor english
i mean i can just say that in every
survey i have seen
of what employers are looking for they
are looking for people who can
communicate well and i repeat this
doesn't mean the accent the accent is a
non-event in my opinion
we have an employee now who's uh russian
he never gets he never gets the articles
like to him
the an
end doesn't exist
but he communicates
very well as did the person we had from
taiwan who moved on to another job he
was with us for 10 years
accent
misses the odd little nicety of the
language but communication first class
unfortunately that is not always the
case in fact often not the case with
immigrants so it is not at all
surprising that potential employers
would react this way they might have
been more favorable
favorably disposed five six years ago
now is this discrimination yeah it's
discrimination based on the experience
of the employer
he discriminates or she discriminates
and i would imagine because this survey
took place in toronto where 50 of the
population roughly is foreign born 50 of
the population is quote a visible
minority there's a very high
chance that a good number of the people
who were looking at these applications
were in fact themselves either born
outside the country or visible
minorities but they still know that
whoever they get to work in their
company has to be able to fit in
so
um
you know and i also object to the fact
that all these government organizations
they get money to do studies to show
that there's great discrimination this
is unfair what
how is that what you know what is the
impact of that on the one hand
the immigrant is beaten up again that's
no fair you're going to be discriminated
against you haven't got a chance what's
the point of sending that message out
the employer on the other hand
it's not going to make him more inclined
to hire immigrants
if anything it might make him more
negatively disposed towards immigrants
what we need to do is talk about the
success success stories everywhere i go
in canada i see lots of immigrants
employed in many different situations
yeah it is difficult it is not fair the
native speaker the native board has a
big advantage yes the native speaker
native born knows the culture knows the
language has friends connections all of
these things that you the immigrant
don't have life is unfair
okay but you came here now you've got to
try to make do
one of the
comments on my blog was from one of our
my good friend mr umberto who is a
longtime user of linguist and linkedin
stuff and he said he was standing in
line with a person from the ukraine who
claimed to have been in la and he lives
in calgary so this was in calgary this
in calgary has been there for three
years and only got six job interviews
well that's just not possible in my
opinion because three years ago in
calgary there
the job market was as tight as can be
and we have a sawmill in northern
alberta where we can't find couldn't
find people now it's completely changed
in the last six months or eight months
but in those days you couldn't find
people we brought in
uh technical people from the philippines
we hired two uh technical people
from china and they were all very well
accepted and they managed to communicate
fine so
all i'm saying is we shouldn't always be
looking for examples of discrimination
and racism and all this other stuff
people have genuine reasons for
and legitimate reasons not that that's
not to say that there aren't people out
there with prejudices and the people
with prejudices are not limited to
people in the mainstream economy in fact
probably the mainstream employer is more
open-minded than
the ethnic employer i mean
you know there's a
multicultural radio station here in
vancouver and other than the people who
do the recording in spanish and
slovakian and korean every other
employee in that operation is chinese
guess who owns it i mean let's get
serious that's the way people are we
should stop whining and be positive of
what we about we what we can do
as immigrants to improve our
opportunities i better get off here bye